لتخبرنا لماذا تفكر أولاً من الناحية
الإستراتيجية ، هذا هو الشيء الصحيح الذي يجب
فعله لأنك تعلم أن الكثير من الناس يقولون
انظروا إلى أن هذا كان روسيًا حتى
قالها خروتشوف في عام 1954 أن هذا
سيكون خط بوتين الأحمر الذي سيكون هو
الشيء الوحيد  إنه 95 يتحدث الروسية ،
هذا هو المجال الوحيد الذي
لا ينبغي أن تدخله أوكرانيا إليك ، على العكس من ذلك ، قل
إلى حد كبير أنه المكان الذي
يجب أن تنظم فيه أوكرانيا ابتكارًا ،
لذلك من المهم أن تتذكر بالطبع
أن الجميع بما في ذلك
الولايات المتحدة يدركون أن شبه جزيرة القرم  هي
منطقة ذات سيادة لأوكرانيا ، لذلك
لا يوجد نزاع على سيادة شبه جزيرة
القرم كجزء من أوكرانيا.
لن تكون
مستقرة أو آمنة أو آمنة أبدًا طالما أن
القوات الروسية لا تزال تحتل شبه جزيرة القرم
ولن تتمكن أبدًا من إعادة بناء
اقتصادها طالما أن الأسطول الروسي
يبحر هناك من سيفاستوبول الذي
يعترض حركة المرور القادمة
من أوديسا وإليها.  ما هو حاسم
كيف يمكننا الضغط على أوكرانيا للمضي
قدمًا والتخلي عن شبه جزيرة القرم ،
حسنًا ، لذا اشرح لنا الآن سبب إمكانية
تنفيذها عسكريًا ، أعني أن روسيا
بلد أكبر بكثير ، فهذه مسألة
فخر بالنسبة لهم
لأنهم اقتصاد أكبر بكثير.  الدفاع
أه الميزانية ومع ذلك فأنت تقول إن هذا ممكن ،
لذا فأنا لست متأكدًا من أنها
مسألة فخر لجميع الروس ،
ستتذكر 500000 روسي غادروا
البلاد العام الماضي بدلاً من
حشدهم ، أنا متأكد من أنهم يحبون الذهاب  أسفل شبه
جزيرة القرم إلى البحر الأسود لقضاء
إجازتهم كما رأينا الصيف الماضي ، لكن
لا يوجد جنود روس يريدون أن يكونوا
في أوكرانيا ، فإن الحرب هي اختبار للإرادة
واختبار الخدمات اللوجستية ، فإن النظام اللوجستي الروسي
بالكاد قادر على إمداد
القوات الروسية  أن
أسطول البحر الأسود الروسي
مرعوب من الذهاب إلى أي مكان بالقرب من
الساحل الأوكراني وأوكرانيا ليس
لديها حتى البحرية ، لذلك أعتقد أنه عندما تبدأ في
مقارنة السكان
والأنظمة اللوجستية ، فإن أوكرانيا لا تعاني من مشكلة في القوى العاملة.  لقد
حصلنا على أكثر من 700000 شخص
يرتدون الزي العسكري ومليونان آخران على
استعداد للتقدم إلى الأمام وبالطبع
قوة الإرادة ، من الواضح جدًا أن
الأوكرانيين لديهم الإرادة المتفوقة للجنود
وكذلك الشعب كما هو
الحال في روسيا وأعتقد أن هذا هو ما
أنت عليه.  في إشارة إلى ما تمتلكه روسيا
بالطبع هو الكتلة ، فهم لا يهتمون بعدد
القتلى ، ونرى أنهم
يخسرون ما بين ستة ولا يقتل 800 شخص
يوميًا ، وسيواصلون دفع تلك
القوات إلى مفرمة اللحم على أمل
في النهاية
سيطر على المدافعين الأوكرانيين
ولكن كما يقول ساكورا الجنرال كافولي هو
القائد الأعلى للحلفاء ، فأنت
دقيق يمكنه هزيمة الكتلة إذا كان لديك
ما يكفي من الوقت